and I would get asked kind of a lot um
did you test the lifespan in these worms
I would say uh yeah we want to we're
going to do it and uh eventually I did
it and we we found it it seemed to be
living longer and I was like well I've
never done a lifespan experiment before
I better do it a few times it seems to
be reproducible
and at the same time as we got those
results I was getting more and more
interested in aging because of the
hypoxia literature and how different
protective paradigms and hypoxia seem to
not work with old age and I was thinking
if we're studying heart attack and
stroke using things that don't work in
older animals like what are we even
doing so I wanted to learn more about
aging and that's that's when I started
talking with Matt caberline and uh I
showed them these optogenetic results
with Mito on and he was happy to have me
come join the lab and figure out what
exactly was going on in these worms so
hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video I spoke with Dr
Brandon Berry a current postdoctoral
fellow at the University of Washington
where he's developing and using tools to
understand the function of mitochondria
and their links with the season aging
here we discuss season trust father and
the results from his latest publication
by the tool extended blam lifespan
so hi friends and uh thank you for
joining me today and welcome to the
Chica Science Show
thank you so much for having me I'm
really excited
great because I'm really interested to
hear more about your research
um and how you manipulate mitochondria
and by for before we go there um it's
kind of known that mitochondrial
dysfunction is Hallmark of Aging as I
was wondering if you could explain what
are mitochondria are and how does your
research relate to addressing the link
between mitochondrial dysfunction and
aging
yeah so mitochondria are the best
organelles ever
um they're these evolutionarily ancient
uh they seems like they used to be
microbes free living and eukaryotic
cells
um engulfed them so they've been
evolving with life uh with as long as
life has been complex there's been
mitochondria
and what mitochondria do classically uh
everyone knows them as the PowerHouse of
the cell and because that's because they
they make ATP so ATP is the cellular
energy currency and if you think about
it everything that the cell does any
action that the cell takes is going to
require energy and most of the time that
energy comes from mitochondria
so that's why we think that
mitochondrial dysfunction is like a core
Hallmark of aging and we think it
probably underlies a lot of the other
it's not all of the other Hallmarks of
AJ um just because when it comes down to
it if there's energy defects there's
going to be problems
yeah both sides and so you'll say one
thing that um is pretty important for
what your research is is looking at
um the components that are found within
the mitochondria the membrane and
obviously it's linked with like aerobic
respiration and as you said the
generation of ATP so
um I think one thing we should probably
discuss in detail is how is that process
um and how does that process work and
how does it involve proton transports
yeah yeah so
the core part of mitochondrial function
that I'm really interested in is the
membrane potential which is part of this
proton motive Force so mitochondria
function I I call it a battery charge
it's very similar to a battery
um so there are two membranes the
mitochondria outer membrane the inner
membrane inner membrane there's an
electrochemical gradient so there's a
proton gradient it's positively charged
hydrogen ions are separated across this
membrane
so the positive charge on the protons is
responsible for most of that driving
force
there's a pH separation as well so just
the pure concentration gradient adds
some of that potential energy as well
but it's it's mostly membrane potential
so the membrane potential is the charge
and the pH potential is the
concentration of gradient so proton
motive force is both of them and it's
kind of used interchangeably like people
will say membrane potential to mean the
whole gradient and I think that's mostly
because the best ways to measure it
you're only really measuring the
electrical component but because that's
most of it it's kind of all people look
at sometimes
so that's membrane potential
and how that membrane potential gets
established is through some enzymes in
the mitochondrial inner membrane called
the electron transport chain and what
happens is is literally combustion so
just like in a in a power plant a carbon
source is burned to extract energy in
some way so the combustion that happens
in mitochondria the carbon source is
food
and the energy present is extracted
through different redox reactions in the
electron transport Gene and what happens
with there's some energy in those redox
reactions that pumps protons from inside
the mitochondria to outside and that
establishes this potential gradient more
protons outside than inside and that
that's where the membrane potential uh
comes from
and so what the membrane potential then
does gets used to make ATP through the
ATP synthase that's also in the inner
membrane memory of mitochondria so
there's a chemical energy in food that
gets converted into this electrical
energy that gets converted back into a
chemical energy that the cell can
recognize and use
um so that's the PowerHouse analogy but
we should also say that um we really
know that mitochondria are a lot more
than just powerhouses they do provide
ATP but there's a lot of good articles
actually summarizing all of the other
stuff that mitochondria do
um they influence lots of different
things like hormone production immunity
um so they're not just powerhouses and
the the analogy that I like to use is
like
calling mitochondria Powerhouse of the
cell is like hauling a smartphone a
calculator
where it's like that's true but it kind
of misses the point of what they are and
what they do
um so yeah that's that's uh I like to
think about it
no I like to think that's a cool way to
think about it
um and so you've mentioned this person
makes a force and um how the persons get
put into the the space between the
membranes but how do you actually go
about measuring what that uh potential
is and how does that potential change
with age
yeah so measuring it can be pretty
difficult
it's really difficult if you want to
measure it in an animal kind of like how
we're doing in our animal model but
traditionally how this is done is using
isolated mitochondria so researchers can
isolate mitochondria from cells or
Animals by grinding up tissue doing
different laboratory steps to just get
pure mitochondria and then you can
measure this gradient using small
molecules that are positively charged so
the positive charge will be attracted to
the inside of mitochondria because you
have positive charges outside negative
charges inside so there are these fatty
molecules that have a positive charge
that will accumulate inside mitochondria
and some of them are fluorescence you
could measure the fluorescence
accumulation
um you can use it with electrodes there
are molecules that you can measure
electric fields and and determine how
much the mitochondria are taking up
um but then once you get into cells it
gets a little bit harder into whole
tissues it's a little bit harder and
that whole animals it's really
really unclear what could be going on
but we gave it a shot
and so is that when any studies that
I've looked at
um like how this membrane potential is
linked with different life diseases or
like educational diseases
yeah yeah so there have been early
indications in yeast models that it
seems like this uh potential declines
with age the client's pretty early with
age which is what we found in our model
as well
and it's known that the the proton
motive force is implicated in lots of
different diseases so
mitochondria are involved in like any
disease you can think of there's
energetic defect and mitochondria are
likely to be involved at some level
um so probably the earliest example of
looking at mitochondrial membrane
potential and disease is uh in
cardiovascular diseases like heart
attack and stroke where mitochondrial
membrane potential seems to fluctuate
and there's lots of cool data out there
I I studied this uh during my PhD I did
heart attack and stroke models
and part of what we wanted to do was
look at how changes in mitochondrial
membrane potential would influence the
outcome from heart attack and stroke
models
so it's it's one of those things that's
such a fundamental process to
mitochondrial function where like once
you start looking at it there are
changes happening but it's usually
unclear what those changes mean or lead
to
okay
and so you sort of alluded to some of
your PhD work and obviously you've
continued uh some of that onto your pay
stalk and published the paper that came
out just last week and so
um you describe a tool called
mitochondria on and this is a way to
sort of manipulate or to increase this
proton meta Force so I was wondering if
you could get some sort of like
backstory to how this will start it and
how you develop the tool yeah so it all
started at the beginning of my PhD
actually so I was in a lab that used C
elegans which we can talk about uh some
reasons to use C elegans but uh this the
lab uh is uh led by Andrew watovich
um who is on the paper that we recently
published as well we still work pretty
closely with Andrew and when I joined
the lab
um he had this project so his lab uses
optogenetics to control many different
aspects of mitochondrial function
and so optogenetics is this cool tool
kit that is used in Neuroscience a lot
uh where they use light sensitive
proteins to control some aspect of
physiology so usually they're light
activated channels or pumps that are in
membranes so you can control Action
potentials and neurons and dissection or
all circuits so being hardcore
mitochondrial biologists knowing that
proton motive force is uh the driving
force of mitochondrial function it kind
of followed that you could use a light
activated proton pump can we stick it in
the inner membrane of mitochondria and
control that gradient
so we actually ended up doing that in
both directions so we created tools
called mitochondria on or Mito on and
mitochondria off or Mito off so this is
just light activated proton pump facing
in either direction you can do some
molecular tricks to flip the direction
of the proton pump and get the proton
pump in different directions
so it took a long time for me to develop
uh the tool we tried a lot of different
strategies and eventually I got it to
work and we're very happy for that
um and so yeah I used it to study
hypoxia biology and see elegans worms
and near the end of my PhD I got really
interested in aging
um I think a lot of us get interested in
aging because it kind of comes up in in
the course of your research that things
start to change when animals get older
and I just started to say like why is
that and can we use these tools to study
aging itself
that's interesting and so
um like talk a bit more about the the
mechanism of uh this tool that you
developed how exactly like what is the
protein that you've used and did you
test different proteins because it's um
obviously a proton
um it's a light sensitive proton pump
right yep yeah
yeah so we tried um two different
versions actually there are a lot
there's probably way more now even so
when I was early in my PhD there were
probably tens of different proton pumps
people will go in and change different
residues to make them a little bit more
efficient or responsive to a different
color of light but for the most part
they're all related to the protein
bacteria rhodopsin so seven
transmembrane Alpha helices there's a
cofactor in the protein called All Trans
retinal or ATR so this is a cofactor
that absorbs the energy from light and
it does a rearrangement that forces the
protein to rearrange so proton so a
proton on one side of the membrane will
be able to get out on the other side of
the membrane
and as long as light is Illuminating the
protein this molecule will cycle and
protons will get pumped until the light
is turned off
so we actually use the proton pump from
a eukaryotic organism even though it's
bacteria adoption related a eukaryotic
microbe that uses these proton pumps to
sense light and to move toward the light
to do photosynthesis
um it's one of the common ones that's
used in optogenetics and we also used a
similar proton pump from a bacterial
organism and it just turned out that
this one got expressed better first and
we just ran with it
yeah it sounds like science um that's
really interesting
um the song I was going to say
um yeah so you've mentioned that it uses
light to activate this proton pumping um
ability of the movement of protons but
what sort of wavelength of light are you
using and
um do you control the wavelength of
light and does that have any
consequences with like heat transfer as
well in these experiments yeah yeah so
luckily the light that these pumps
mostly use like I said there are some
that shift the wavelengths a little bit
um it's 590 nanometers which is yellow
greenish light
which is not the most damaging color for
mitochondrial
um proteins and for for biological
tissue like blue light can be pretty
damaging on its own and cause some
oxidation
um so it's it's not the worst color of
light
but the really great thing is that in
our models do we use C elegans nematode
worms they actually don't produce that
cofactor all trans retinal
so we have to feed that cofactor to them
so that's a really great control for the
light exposure so we can have worms that
are expressing the protein we hit them
with light
but there's going to be no optogenetic
activity so we know that the light
itself is not you know burning them up
or having some off-target effects so we
know the combination of the cofactor and
the light is when the optogenetics is
active so we use that condition to
compare to all the other conditions
um so for that reason we really like
using the worms with optogenetics
because it's internally controlled where
in mammalian tissue we have a synthetic
pathway for all trans retinals it's
vitamin A
um so it gets a little bit harder to
control so I like using worms in
conjunction with other models to uh you
know be sure that we're studying what
we're studying
yeah that's a great control and um as
you mentioned earlier so why is it
besides this point that you're using
Seattle guns obviously there's a lot of
advantages but um one of the main ones
yeah yeah so C elegans are great for
optogenetics uh purely because they're
transparent you can illuminate all of
their tissues you can see all of their
tissues you can do fluorescence
microscopy and see what's going on
you can see
um measurements of the mitochondrial
membrane potential using these
fluorescence dyes in the worms you can
stain the worms and kind of get an idea
of what the mitochondrial membrane
potential might be there's some caveats
with that
um but it's pretty useful
and then the reason for using worms in
general
um especially for aging they have a very
short lifespan you can do whole
population lifespan studies in around a
month a little bit longer than a month
um sometimes a couple weeks
they have highly evolutionarily
conserved mitochondria
um kind of like I talked about at the
beginning but mitochondria are very
conserved because it seems to be that
they were
evolutionarily ancient
so a lot of what we actually know about
mitochondrion mammals comes from studies
and see elegans early on and a lot of
what we know about aging uh comes from
Clans so I think it's a it's a great
model to nail down the fundamental
biology before
um chasing down things in more
complicated models
exactly and I guess one of the more
recent advances with working with worms
as well is the the ability to sort of
genetically engineer them so I was
curious like how did you
um Express this mitochondrial on um tool
into the worms yeah so we did it a
couple different ways
um
the first way is kind of the classic uh
C elegans transgenesis where you can
just take plasmid DNA and inject it into
their gonad and then their progeny will
take up this plasmid as an extra
chromosomal array so if I have this
plasmid floating around and they'll
Express the protein from that
um that was hard to do because it turns
out if you try sending a lot of this
Mito on protein to mitochondria the
worms are pretty sick so we had to find
like the Goldilocks amount of DNA to
give them
at the same time Andrew's lab was
developing a crispr technique to
in a defined way insert one copy of a
gene
in one place in the genome where we knew
where it was
so we ended up doing both of those
methods and the crispr strain
um
worked basically the same as the over
expression strain so we were very happy
for that we had two different genetic
backgrounds to test it in and now we're
just using the crispr strain
because it's uh we know it's in the
genome and you control the expression a
little bit better
and so why I guess you are over
expressing it consecutively or was it I
guess you can control it
um obviously the activity at the light
level but in terms of personal
expression that was continuous yeah so
it's over expressed with the extra
chromosomal array because you don't
really know how many copies of the array
there is and in the crispr strain we
know there's a single copy and we're
using an endogenous promoter so it's
expressed under the eft3 promoter uh
just a random
pretty common worm promoter and then
it's also tagged with a fluorescence
protein so we can actually see that it's
expressed in the worm and we can see
that it's in mitochondria in the world
so yeah we think the expression is is
pretty um
low to medium expression it's not super
highly expressed
okay and socially the major finding from
your recent paper is that by having this
activation of this
um mitochondrial on tool you were able
to extend the lifespan of the worms so
was that a surprise in finding
yes yes it was very surprising um so
early in my PhD I I was focused on
cardiovascular stuff and hypoxia and I
would get asked kind of a lot um did you
test the lifespan in these worms I would
say yeah we want to we're going to do it
and uh eventually I did it and we we
found it it seemed to be living longer
and I was like well I've never done a
lifespan experiment before I better do
it a few times it seems to be
reproducible
and at the same time as we got those
results I was getting more and more
interested in aging because of the
hypoxia literature and how different
protective paradigms and hypoxia seem to
not work with old age and I was thinking
if we're studying heart attack and
stroke using things that don't work in
older animals like what are we even
doing so I wanted to learn more about
aging and that's that's when I started
talking with Matt caberline and uh I
showed them these optogenetic results
with Mito on and he was happy to have me
come join the lab and figure out what
exactly was going on in these worms
um so I did the lifespan and the crispr
strain so the first time we did it was
in the over expression screen
and I did the lifespan in the crispr
Stream out here in Seattle and Andrew's
lab back in New York
um was was doing more lifespans and kind
of surprisingly it worked every time and
we
thought it was really cool didn't know
how to explain it kind of still don't
know how to explain it which is exciting
uh because there's a lot to do and
there's a lot of stuff that I wanted to
follow up on and I think
yeah when you study mitochondrial
membrane potential there's so many
things
um to follow up with so that's why I
like this stuff
um but yeah it was definitely unexpected
um and just the fact that we could see
the mitochondrial membrane potential
decline with age so early in Age Two
they're young adult worms and you can
already see their losing membrane
potential pretty fast and this is
um
supported by the yeast the early yeast
work as well they they lose mitochondria
membrane potential pretty fast
um so yeah it was all surprising and all
uh cool to do
yeah for sure I like I guess say like
one rationale then is that if this is
decline in the pmf this person makes a
force with age that what the
mitochondrial one is doing is sort of
like rescuing the decline
yeah yeah that's yeah we think it's kind
of
slowing down the decline at least
but again it can be hard to kind of put
a timeline on it when it's hard to
measure in Vivo but yeah we think it's
at least slowing down the decline
um kind of recharging the battery
uh technology
and so another thing I was going to say
or like at least I think it's worth
pointing out is that you started the
um the activation of the protein tool at
day one so that's after the worms are
fully developed yeah did you test it in
a developmental stage as well yeah so we
have some lifespan experiments during
development um Andrew's lab is more
focused on doing those experiments and I
think we have some some pretty solid
results so far
um
but I really wanted to
study this during adulthood
um just because
even though we're using the wear model
I'm always trying to think
translationally and we we can't really
do anything right now during development
for aging but we could start to do
something when someone is already aging
so I thought it was important to show
that this is something we can do during
adulthood
and I also thought that it was cool to
do that because
most if not all of the mitochondrial
interventions and worms have to happen
during development to extend lifespan
so you can do different things to mess
around with mitochondria and worms and
they'll get a long lifespan but if you
don't do that during development they
won't get the lifespan extension so
that's interesting it's very interesting
but maybe a little bit harder to
translate so I wanted to be sure that
this was something
we could uh do during adulthood
cool yeah and I think well some other
question I had was um you said at the
start so you decided to pay with this
mitochondrial until but if you flip the
orientation you can also push the
protons back the other way and have
looks like
um to decrease the price I made to force
yeah if the G test lifespan in that
state did it decreased the
um I guess that'd make the the ones very
sick
yeah so it did not make the worms very
sick
um the lifespan I think is still unclear
we haven't
um fully you know characterized it as
much as we have with Mito on with might
want like we have dozens of lifespan
experiments by now which is crazy to
think about so we haven't fully
characterized it enough in the middle
off screen but we do know that like
they're not they don't die instantly
they're not super sick
when I first made the strain I thought
for sure they were gonna die instantly I
was like we're gonna turn off the
mitochondria and they're gonna just die
and they didn't so I think that suggests
that you know the proton pumps
are maybe not able to totally collapse
in that brain potential which you know
makes sense because the mitochondria are
still intact they can make their own
rate module
um also like there's metabolic
compensation so like maybe the worms are
ramping up glycolysis to me
so they don't need their mitochondria
lots lots to figure out with that
straight as well
yeah no I reckon that's like loads of
interesting questions you could address
with that strain
um but say this is so far I guess uh one
thing I'm interested in and it's like
what do you think called the next steps
of taking this tool further obviously
like one thing would be interesting
would be to somehow translate it to mice
I guess as you mentioned C elegans these
phones they're transparent so it's very
easy to manipulate yes and activate the
tool
yeah so we've actually
um we've got some preliminary data
published
um in HEX cells and in Mass T cells
um from a couple of years ago now
um so we we have this expressed in HEX
cells we're working on expressing it in
other cell lines and we're actually able
to show in Mouse T cells
um we can make the cells more active so
the idea is if you could for
immunotherapy car T cell replacement
therapy if you can give mitochondria a
boost in the tumor micro environment
where there's not as much oxygen and it
seems like we can make these cells
persist in a tumor micro micro
environment for a little bit longer than
they normally would so this was our
first indication that this is going to
do something in mammals and we're
working on getting a mouse strain made
at least to do tissue biology so you can
you know expose tissue to light pretty
easily but there are pretty cool ways to
expose animals to light so this lab at
University of Rochester that we
collaborated with it that did this
T-cell project
um they do this cool technique they do a
bunch of different optogenetic
interventions in T cells and I think
they use a skin cancer model and what
they do is they'll attach a little LED
light to the ear on a mouse and they can
you know have uh light on both ears but
the cells in in one or the other or
something like that
um so yeah we're definitely thinking
about mammalian translation and we're
trying to get this Mouse made
so very excited to have that in the near
future I hope
yeah for sure um and I think like
another interesting thing which you do
some sort of tests in this paper is like
how
um you might be able to manipulate
lifespan further by combining this
approach with other known like lifespan
um extension techniques so like one
thing you test in this paper is
um the ampk activation pathway
um which is yeah I mean would you like
to elaborate on that yeah excuse me
so yeah we wanted to know
what is the mechanism Downstream so
we're like preventing this decline in
memory potential or giving them a boost
recharging the battery whatever
that's signaling through something
um or you know it could just be like
they're making more ATP and Powerhouse
of the cell that's it
um I don't suspect that's it so we
wanted to test something that is kind of
just adjacent to that which the first
thing we you think to test is amp kinase
so amp kinase
kind of maybe using the smartphone
analogy this is like the low power mode
um notification you get when when the
energy is low ampk comes on and tries to
do something about it can change how
energy
um is is made for the cell
so we know from my previous Publications
that both mighto on and Mido off can
change the phosphorylation status of
ampk under certain situations
and we know that ampk activation extends
lifespan and worms and flies and in
other muscles
so we thought okay let's cross the Mito
on screen into the active ampk strain
and if the lifespan is not additive then
that's some evidence that marijuana is
working through ampk signaling which
kind of made sense to us
worms were like way longer lived seemed
kind of additive maybe a little bit more
than additive
um so very cool again don't know why
so
so more to follow up I think that it
suggests that the amp kinase lifespan
extension and Mito online extension are
working in different maybe parallel
Pathways
um which is cool
um there are there's not one way to
lifespan extension so if mito1 can be
used to boost the other ways to extend
lifespan that's that's great
um
so yeah that's kind of where where we
were for the amp kinase
um we wanted to get this finding
published so we were not the only ones
toiling away at these lifespanes anymore
um so we wanted to show
we got this result we tried one
mechanism doesn't seem like that was it
here you go everyone
so um yeah we're still following up with
the ampy kinase and a bunch of other
Pathways as well but again there's so
much work to do
um figuring out what's going on that I
think it's I I hope it's going to be a
great resource for people to test their
favorite whatever with
yeah for sure and I think
um yeah there's like so many potential
applications of it and again there's
also I guess many ways you could combine
it with different things like um
yeah color like the calorie restriction
um models but also yeah yeah there could
be like whole um like I don't know
actually too much about C elegans and
the extent of like Christopher uh Gene
editing approaches but can you do like
um knock down a different like Library
approaches to knock down different genes
yeah yeah I would love to do that I also
really want to get um like other kinds
of screens or just like looking at uh we
already have some uh proteomics in the
paper
um which is part of a larger data set
that we're working on uh just to see how
how protein levels change we want to see
how expression levels of different
things change just purely in the turn on
Moto on or leave it off and see see
what's different
um crispr screen sounds awesome as well
um yeah I think it's a great way to do
that I
I don't know if worms would be a great
place to do it but I think cell culture
would maybe be an easier and more
informative way place to do it and I'd
like I'd like to do that as well
um but yeah I think it's it's uh promise
as a screening tool is is really cool
because you can
what it does is basically makes
mitochondrial membrane potential an
independent variable
which before this technique is kind of
impossible to do in Vivo
because things are feeding into
mitochondrial function and things are
coming out of mitochondrial function so
if you see a change in mitochondrial
membrane potential it's like well is
that causing something to change or did
something cause it to change or with
these techniques you can say we're
controlling it and then what happens so
it's it's true like causal metabolism
which is
um going to be useful for a lot of stuff
yeah I'm sure it's like good good way to
design experiments and so like as well
um with like further experiments
um and how the mitochondria is involved
in like more than just being this
Powerhouse of the cells you as you
mentioned I really do like that
smartphone analogy
um but like so the mitochondria are also
entirely linked with like Zelda from
regulating apoptosis did you see like
because yeah
um was there any sort of uh analysis on
like cell deaf and how that was
influenced in your studies
no we haven't really looked in um
yeah I think there was a paper using a
different kind of Mido off so this was a
channel so it wasn't a specific proton
pump but it was just a cation channel
that they targeted to mitochondria so
when they use blue light they would kind
of open a pore in the mitochondria it
kind of achieved the same thing it
turned down the membrane potential and
they actually measured in
I'm not gonna remember the cell type but
some some human cell line I think
um and they showed that it actually does
influence
um cell viability
so it's kind of interesting that in the
whole animals you know we didn't see
like no more animals I mean more animals
survived longer
um with Mito on and with Mito off there
was nothing clear like 20 of the
population died instantly or whatever
which is kind of what I thought might
happen because of that so you know you
make a pour in the mitochondrial
membrane should that trigger apoptosis
and yeah I don't know
but yeah so so there are other versions
of the off
um that have been published and they did
look at that
and another thing that I thought was
interesting from I think it was your
2020 paper where you do more of the tool
development was that you showed how like
obviously the current people suggest
that having a high pmf this proton motor
force is good for extending lifespan but
is it in your opinion good to always
have a very high protein metaphorce
um or is there evidence that maybe
um intermittent times because
um I might be
um remembering your 2020 paper but there
were some suggestions that it was good
to have a slight depletion in the pmf so
that develop some sort of like response
and stress response uh
yeah so the disclaimer here is that most
of what we know about pmf changes is
from isolated mitochondrion cells so
when it starts coming into like disease
and aging the real answer is we don't
really know and that's like where The
Cutting Edge is
but based on all of the theory from
isolated experiments
having a high memory potential all the
time is probably not good
uh what what can happen is if the Mito
membrane potential is too high it can
cause a back pressure on the electron
transport chain
kind of like you have a hose flowing you
just put your thumb on the end of the
hose and it's going to like cause
pressure and maybe expose some leaks in
the hose
um and and those leaks would be oxidant
production from mitochondria so oxidants
have kind of been a little bit of a
boogeyman in the field of aging and now
we kind of know that it's more nuanced
than that sometimes oxidants can be Pro
survival sometimes they're damaging
um but we know if the mitochondrial
membrane potential is too high they will
make lots of oxidants
um so what I currently think based on
lots of different literature is that if
you have a low
a pathologically low membrane potential
your membrane potential is declining
with age then it's good to give it a bit
of a recharge
I don't know if it's good to
charge it up so much that you're
overcharged
um and I also think it depends on the
health of the electron transport chain
itself
so a low membrane potential could be
adaptive so I don't have any evidence
for this but just in theory if you have
damaged electron transport chain that
just really wants to make damaging
oxidants the cell could respond by
turning down the membrane potential to
kind of say don't make any accidents
please so then if you make the membrane
potential higher it can force bad things
to happen
so this is this is the difficulty in
studying mitochondrial membrane
potential and trying to relate what we
know in isolation to what we know in
Vivo and you know this is what I want my
lab to focus on in the future is
what do we know about mitochondrion
isolation and what can we take from that
into a an animal and eventually into a
human
um can we achieve like through
mitochondrial medicine
because I think it's kind of surprising
that we know so much about how
mitochondria work like high school
thought about how mitochondria works and
there's nothing you can do if you go to
a hospital with some condition
there's nothing you can do to directly
Target your mitochondrial function very
little you can actually do it's like why
is that why do we know so much but we
don't have tons of ways to treat uh
mitochondria and I think there are lots
of promising ways but we need to
understand the fundamental biology a lot
better before that's ever going to be
useful so that's where I would like to
have my lab work in that interface
yeah for sure that sounds awesome and I
think yeah obviously speaking um this
session like there's so many questions
that we sort of fully understand like I
teach to some extent the like the
election transport chain to students and
I'm like the same ones who didn't really
understand Jazz and that they're like
they sort of like learn it for rates but
um yeah this super interesting and they
actually brought up oxidants obviously
there's some literature supporting that
in increasing antioxidants like Cohen's
and Q I believe declines of age
um there's some evidence for that and so
that is
um one of these sort of antioxidant
molecules and so do you think that
combining that with having
um a boosted Mighty on my uh like
synergize
yeah it definitely could I think it
could be easy to test especially in
worms it could be easy to test that
um and you know other redox metabolites
too I mean NAD is super hot right now in
in aging and NAD is you know part of the
part of the process that leads to
membrane potential creation
um so I think all these things are kind
of keystones of metabolism happening in
mitochondria and how they could add with
each other will be really interesting to
find out
yeah for sure and so um obviously
besides NAD is there any other like
areas in the longevity field at the
moment that you think is quite
interesting
yeah I mean I'm I only got into aging
like you know a few a few years ago and
I have learned a lot uh getting into
this field
I am really sort of in awe of cellular
senescence and how mitochondria
seems like mitochondria are playing a
big role at cellular senescence you know
like everything else
how are they well we don't know and
maybe it's oxidants you know I think
maybe it's mitochondrial membrane
potential um
senescent cells their mitochondria can't
seem to hold on to as much calcium
calcium is positively charged and
calcium is loaded into mitochondria
according to the membrane potential that
points toward membrane potential so
that's you know my link between the
Hallmarks of Aging
and to me cellular senescence it seems
like
again it's like something that's at The
Cutting Edge of human knowledge it's
like what are senescent cells what is
aging really how are mitochondria
involved so I have this sort of
mitochondrial bias to everything that I
think of but it opens the doors to uh
other cool areas
um so yeah I guess my biggest
um interested area would be cellular
senescence right now
I'm glad to hear that
um yeah but that already made me think
of so many different things because
um yeah also one thing we've there's
some slight I've not done it personally
but I know people who are trying to look
at the mitochondrial metabolism and how
it changes in senescence
um and obviously like one of the
challenges is actually being able to
study mitochondria and like the the
tools
um that we developed are getting better
I think um obviously I think even
applying this and inducing senescence in
like the car models yeah you could boost
the pmf without
um change the decision process um
obviously I study p53 which sort of
seems to somehow decide between
senescence and cell death and obviously
then that links both them back to
apoptosis and I'm sorry the mitochondria
um
so oh man you made me think of so many
interesting things yeah I mean if you
want a plasma let me know I'll send it
out
well after me when I'm writing my thesis
but um maybe yeah
um and speaking of Academia how have you
found your process obviously you've did
your PC and your pay stock um but you
have any like tips or advice to other
students
yeah yeah for sure so I
um maybe this is becoming a rarer and
rarer occurrence but I had a great
academic experience it's um
Andrew was a great mentor Matt is a
great mentor I was able to have full
ownership over my projects like When
developing Mito on was like an unfunded
project in the lab Andrew let me
he let me go for it you know and I just
uh was
able to do what I wanted with it which
was great and in Matt's lab same thing I
was able to do what I wanted to do
and that's great
it's not it's not the case a lot of
times in Academia that you can get that
that much Freedom at those stages but my
advice would be
know that you really want to be doing
what you're doing if you want a PhD for
a job
then you you have that reason
if you have a p if you want to do your
PhD because you just love learning about
the topic that you're learning about
that's a great reason
if you feel like you have to get a PhD
for some reason that you don't yet
understand I would say don't do it it's
not worth it you have to love it if you
don't love it it will be very hard it's
very hard when you do love it it's a lot
of
it's a lot of work and not even in the
sense that
I I have I have had and continue to have
great work-life balance like I've
figured out how to make that work for
myself but it's still
you know it wears on you having an
unanswered question like doing a PhD is
living with an unanswered question for
three four five six seven years that's
hard to do
um the structure of Academia is also
hard to work with you have to you know
move for your postdoc move after your
postdoc move again potentially
um and that's hard to deal with so yeah
my advice is
know that you love what you're doing and
then just go full into that that passion
and that will help you
um get through it
so that that being said
um I've really started to think less
um monolithically about Academia versus
industry I feel like there is this you
know
fight out there where industry people
are like oh Academia sucks and it's the
worst Academia people are like oh you
don't you dare talk about going into
industry I think
there are really good freedoms and
positives about Academia and there are
really good freedoms and positives about
industry and there are also really bad
negatives about both as well and it's
about finding what you want to actually
do and where does it make sense for you
to do that
so for me I kind of went into it
thinking like well you know I did a PhD
I have to do a postdoc and that was
wrong
um but it worked out for me if it didn't
work out for me you know that would have
been bad so I'm thankful that it did
work out
so I would say before you make those
kind of decisions just know what you
want to do and talk to people and see
where can you realistically do what you
want to do and then do that and that'll
that's a better way to find your path
yeah and I think that's good advice and
the other thing um because obviously I'm
very impressed if like how you sort of
have this like very logical approach
with um your studies and how you had a
finding and this makes you think of this
and then you do that and like I'm
definitely like sort of just
um your basic sort of tips as like
dealing with experimental design or like
how you go about approaching your
research questions
yeah so for experimental design it's
been a long process to learn how to do
that that's that's part of doing a PhD
and like and still in the postdoc too is
learning how to do that
um
Andrew can take some credit for teaching
me that
um I'll say early early in my PhD I
wanted to do everything I I still want
to do everything I talk about how cool
it is to do everything and he would say
Brandon just do this experiment stop
stop all of this and just do the
experiment and then once I did that I
was like oh my gosh it worked and now
the next step is clear
so part of the advice that I can pass on
is if you have a good experiment just do
it and then decide what to do next
yeah no I definitely could have learned
that faster than I did
um
yeah
um I see just to sort of wrap up about
any sort of like
um besides like obviously the research
that you're doing and any sort of like
interesting
um like areas that you're excited to see
to follow up in the next couple of years
yeah so I I mean I would really like to
see more people incorporating our
optogenetic tools
um because I think
it's a way to kind of take mitochondria
out of the equation where where so often
like so many people are interested in
mitochondria now
um and Metabolism in general
and I think it's a great toolkit to just
say okay we're going to make this an
independent variable so we can kind of
remove it from the equation
so again in cellular senescence I really
I'm learning more about how to uh study
cellular senescence in in different
small ways and I'm really excited to see
how combining
metabolic approaches like this
uh with cellular senescence research
where that's gonna go
and other areas that I think are really
interesting in development
um I think there's a lot of Imaging
approaches that are just so so cool and
it's changing very rapidly
um
I think Brian glancy's Lab at the NIH
has some awesome tools to look at
mitochondria in Vivo or in C2 C2 and
just seeing how
in a very short period of time we went
from seeing mitochondria as
Street objects in the microscope so now
we can see the inner membrane and the
Chris day and what it all looks like and
we can see that the Chris Day have
different membrane Potentials in
different areas and how it looks in
muscles versus liver versus brain and I
think the Imaging is just progressing so
fast I'm really excited to see
um where that's going to go is it gonna
Plateau is going to get even better
yeah very exciting
I mean speaking actually I was going to
ask you about
um like using microscopy to look at the
localization of um the mitochondrial on
protein because obviously I made the the
crystal is very like
um it's highly stretched um uh
compartmentalized in terms of the ATV
synthase so if they form these timers
and they sort of seem to be at the tips
I believe and then yeah I guess we
always see this like linear pathway but
actually they're kind of clustered
together and so I guess have you looked
at
um any might um any images to see where
exactly the mitochondrial on proteins
getting um inserted
so no we haven't looked directly but we
know
um
pretty likely where they might have
where might I want is is likely to be
because how I got the Mito on that the
proton pump
targeted to mitochondria
so there are a whole bunch of different
mitochondrial targeting sequences so
like protein sequences that you can just
clone on to the beginning of your
favorite protein and it'll send it into
mitochondria we had to go through a few
different ones to to actually get it to
work and the piece of the protein that
we got to work is from the IMM T1
protein it's immt1 in humans and it is
part of the Christie Junction organizing
complex
so we think that mightawan is
predominantly at Christy Junctions
because of that piece of protein we
don't really know it could it could be
all over because that leader sequence
might not be enough but
um
yeah so we think it's at Christy
Junctions which is probably right next
to ATP synthesis which maybe would make
it oh okay yeah
that's interesting yeah I think that'd
be super interesting to look into
um yeah yeah for sure
so um why can people go to find out more
about your research and to kind of
Follow Your exciting journey into
mitochondrial uh like praise that makes
the false discoveries
um yeah so I I'm pretty active on
Twitter at Mito Brandon that's me
um and yeah I'm I'm here at University
of Washington in Matt cable Line's lab
for the next few months and I'm going to
be transitioning to finish off post-doc
stuff uh in David marcinix lab here at
University of Washington
um where we're going to be looking at
muscle energetics and muscle
mitochondria and uh trying to get this
optogenetic stuff going in some
sarcopenia models we're really excited
about so that's where I'll be for the
near future but always on Twitter I'll
I'll be there
awesome so yeah thank you Brandon for
coming on today and like speaking so
eloquently through your research um it's
been really interesting to hear about it
and this exciting tool that you've
develop that I really do think will have
many applications in particular in
essence hopefully we'll see
um so yeah um just basically
um best of luck with all your future
career plans um and it's just been a
great conversation thank you so much
thank you that's a great compliment and
thank you for having me this is awesome
I'm very happy to have been on and yeah
good luck to you as well finishing off
thank you so I hope you've learned
something in this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening